[Musique]
ah ah
non
[Musique]
m
les anniversaires seront débauchés
jaillet d'anniversaire tu as fais un
voeu
new york 9
[Musique]
non
on a diagnostiqué que max était autiste
à l'âge de trente deux mois chez sfeir a
rejoint la famille à six semaines
puis les crises nocturnes ont cessé
depuis je ne m'inquiète plus vraiment
pour max parce que je sais que chez star
est avec lui ce chien c'est vraiment un
baume apaisant pour notre famille
[Musique]
on est arrivé à grandir au et on s'est
immédiatement bien cherché le matin du
12 septembre
traqueur a trouvé une piste plus tard
les secouristes ont libéré une femme des
décombres c'était la dernière survivante
je suis extrêmement fier du rôle que
traqueur a joué pendant le sauvetage
j'ai bien dit
il a tellement manqué mon coeur chers
[Musique]
non
vous
[Musique]
il
ouais bon jour on vous appelez l'autre
jour pour vous acheter un chiot jacques
j'en avais un paquet ouais une centaine
sa taupe est celle que j'occupe et je
vous fais pas dire
voilà vous pouvez choisir ce qui vous
plaît mais celle là c'est le plus joli
quelques parents chéris elle est trop
mignonne ça allait mais qu'est ce
qu'elle a à l'oeil
on dirait qu'il a l'air affecté à voter
pour choisir un autre nyama 4 mais j'en
vois que 3,1 dernier veut quelque part
par là ils s'échappent de leur cage en
douce il va y avoir ce petit calme et à
la mort
qu'est ce que vous possédez sûr c'est un
bon chien
et donc ils ont tous leur vaccin et tout
ça oui ils sont en bonne santé
voilà c'est quoi
oui
[Musique]
imoca dauphiné c'est fantastique
vraiment c'est bien grâce à ce type
d'action musclées comme celle que sarah
et trevor ont mené que je suis fier de
vous annoncer que le comté de yei tu as
une usine à chiens en moins dont il doit
se préoccuper
cette organisation ne fonctionnerait pas
sans votre passion votre engagement et
votre ténacité
nous vous en sommes reconnaissants je
perds ce matin pour los angeles afin de
participer à goutte d eau s et où je
montrerai les images de ce sauvetage que
nos amis ont mené à bien c'est donc la
première étape de notre campagne
médiatique afin de collecter des fonds
et de faire connaître lui a pas
[Applaudissements]
et sarah cassis voudrais te voir le plus
vite possible
oda 'core rate' avis pourquoi non mais
je suis sûr ce sont de bonnes nouvelles
tu as vraiment fait bouger les choses
merci
au fait avec les filles on sort boire un
verre ce soir tu veux venir
wen
merci à ma voici le dernier communiqué
de presse distribué le s'il vous plaît
nous voilà la femme dit je salue très
bien tu ses bras tu te considères comme
la star de la sauce et je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec lui c'est gentil
notre organisation grandi aujourd'hui on
atteint toutes les capitales d'état et
on côtoie tous les plus grands donateurs
c'est ce que j'ai entendu c'est sir
encourageant et toi sur quoi tu
travailles ces jours ci je suis en train
de faire un tas de recherche sur nos
propositions de réforme de l'élevage et
elle devrait bientôt porter leurs fruits
on a fermé les centres d'élevage d'ici à
san diego
austin albuquerque sur falls il est des
législatures dans une demi-douzaine
détails qui sont en train de passer des
lois ces jours ci pour interdire les
chiens dans les boutiques d'animaux y
les deux ans c'était notre rêve
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité
qu'est ce que tu sais sur la proposition
12 les éleveurs la déteste la
proposition va les obliger à devoir
prendre réellement soin des animaux et
au revoir leurs bénéfices à la baisse
nous voudrions qu'il ait plu au
directeur d'opérations dans nos équipes
de sauvetage ça ne te rendra pas riche
mais ça te ferait une super carte de
visite ici à washington
saumon c'est daniel holloway il élève
des chiens de chasse
on peut dire que c'est un vieux de la
vieille et puis les farouchement opposé
à la proposition 12 et à tout ce qu'on
essaie de faire en général c'est
toujours puisque vous en tant qu'éleveur
de chien responsable voté contre la
proposition 12 afin d'arrêter les
bureaucrates essaie de nous retirer
votre marché vous n'êtes pas à voter a
lancé
de temps à autre monsieur louis engage
des stagiaires qui viennent de
l'université de greenville
brad et moi on disait petit serait
parfaite dans ce rôle là d'accord et
très voir dans tout ça tu sais pour être
honnête j'ai un peu plus confiance en
toi sur ce coup et trevor pour assister
depuis un bureau
ça fait des mois que je leur demande une
mission de ce type
je suis désolé trés voir j'ai aucun
poids sur ses décisions bien sûr
[Musique]
bien sarah nous pensons aux coloris
opère à travers de sites web distinct
qu'il ya la ferme le web pour les chiens
ordinaire et aussi la ferme de paradis à
travers lequel ils vont les chiens qui
sont tombés malades ce qui lui évite de
perdre ses marges bénéficiaires à 500 $
le chiot c'est un énorme business
on a un contact sur place pour toi à
marche field jack et mcconnell
c'est la chef du contrôle des aliments
elle sera très ferme direct se faire
passer pour une étudiante vétérinaire
n'est pas une tâche aisée qui va devoir
étudier afin de savoir vraiment de quoi
tu parles
ce dont on a réellement besoin ce sont
des photos des vidéos des preuves de
négligence d'après nos renseignements il
eu récemment de graves cas de parvovirus
labarthe
si on fait tomber lowell je pense que la
proposition d'où sera dans la boîte
je pense aussi que la personne qui
arrivera risque de recevoir une très
belle promotion que je me calme me fille
unique de s'engager dans une mission
d'infiltration comme un agent de la cia
et elle me demande de me calmer
c'est une preuve de confiance maintenant
et ça veut dire qu'ils croient en moi
mais ils peuvent assurer la sécurité
chérie c'est une organisation à but
depuis quand léo angie organise des
missions d'infiltration franchement
d'accord papa qu'est ce qu'il y a rien
du tout chérie nous dit moi je t'écoute
non c'est juste que je croyais que ces
histoires de sauvetage de chiots c'était
quelque chose que tu faisais pour
t'occuper alors je me demande pourquoi
on a dépensé 100 mille dollars pour ta
licence de marque hissait lui à pea est
l'une des organisations les plus
distingués du pays je t'assure il
pourrait au moins te payer je ne sais
pas pourquoi tu dois faire ça en
cachette parce que c'est quelque chose
en quoi je crois
l'élevage de chiens fils mal bon l'offre
de marx iphone à nantes elle jeudi
sérieuses ont six mois tu pourrais
devenir responsable a requise que tu
écouté tout ce que je viens de dire
et combien de temps dure rester là bas
le temps qu'il faudra pour que je trouve
quelque chose contre ces crapules ces
crapules tu vas commencer ton enquête
avec ce genre d'attitude en tant que
journaliste je ne commence jamais un
article avec présomption de culpabilité
ces gens là sont peut-être des éleveurs
responsable ça ça n'a jamais existé
les pauvres bêtes vivent dans
d'horribles conditions et il contribue à
la surpopulation
lorsque quelqu'un préfère acheter à un
chien d'élevage plutôt que de l'adopter
dans un refuge ça retire un animal sans
foyer une chance d'être adopté et ont le
talent asie c'est un cercle vicieux et
personne ne veut le voir mais c'est la
vérité
nous on n'empêche ça voilà ce qu'on fait
rien n'est tout blanc ou tout noir chéri
e
nous y voilà
[Musique]
sarrassat je suis oui le louer salut je
dois être assez facile à reconnaître
apparemment tu tu devrais peut-être
changer de huy changer de quoi changer
de tenue c'est juste que mon père est
conservateur bien sûr un coup de main
non ça devrait aller d'accord d'accord
mais alors que tu sautes
[Musique]
alors ma mère m'a dit que tu dis
agrippine techniques vétérinaires ça
ouais j'adore les professeurs sont
vraiment excellents et ta famille ça
fait longtemps qu'ils élèvent des chiens
génial et alors tu penses que tu finiras
par prendre le relais ou ouais on dirait
bien
oui mais ça plaît de faire ça
ouais ça va
[Musique]
m
je
tu vas te rendes irlandais t'as pas
réparer la clôture papa tu l'avais
demandé hergé s'est encore échappé je
m'en occupe dans ce ballet qui doit être
sarah moi c'est abigail oui c'est moi
arabi te connais tu connais la
différence entre castrés et stérilisés
tout à fait la castration se fait sur
les mâles et les femelles sont
stérilisés il faut combien de temps pour
sevrer à chiots de sa mère à biscuits la
paix non c'est rien ça va trois ou
quatre semaines
qu'est ce que veut dire était rosi
d'accord c'est bon était ce à lui ça
c'est une vraie école
si moi j'avais que ce serait à billard
est donc était notre invité d'accord
salut je suis holloway ravi de vous
connaître
elle sait pas ce qu hétérozygotes veut
dire bien sûr qu'elle le sait c'est
quand un déjeuner domino et que l'autre
et c6 exact ouais je sais pas comment
j'ai pu oublier
elle ne parle que de ça elle est comme
son père tout son portrait et à ce
propos on devrait aller le rejoindre
j'essaie ainsi ce cas c'est un zealot
c'est génial et chérie voilà la maison
d'amis c'est là que vous le vrai super
et voici la grange pour la reconvertir
en chine il y a quelques années elle est
très jolie
il est sorti et ensuite il s'est coincé
dans la clôture en essayant de rentrer
ce conte elle a réparé dès que je serai
rentré au mélo dans sa cage chérie voici
notre nouvelle stagiaire ça monsieur
webb ravie de faire votre connaissance
vous n'êtes pas du genre à aller sur le
terrain à vrai dire c'est pour ça que je
suis venu pour mettre la main à la pâte
ces dames la saft le s'occuper d'animaux
demande plus que de les promener dans
des sacs de luxe
alors je tâcherai de prendre exemple sur
al chehri sahara était la plus qualifiée
de toutes les candidates ne devait pas y
avoir l'embarras du choix
je peux elle va bientôt mettre banon
salut toi on voit là une jolie fille
attaque secondes
elle en a environ pour trois semaines
ce sera une grosse porte et je vous
donne une journée
vous êtes à l'essai merci jerry va
montrer à sarah où elle dormira d'accord
allez suis moi au fait t'as pas peur des
crotales j'espère ce nom cherry écoute
c'était la seule candidate
on a besoin d aide
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeune fille un portable dans mon jeu
n'est interdit d'accord donnez le moi
vous faites pas de souci je vous le
rendrai j'ai oublié de te dire il dit
qu'il veut pas qu'on poste les trucs
[Musique]
bon
bienvenue dans mon ventre
[Musique]
non
où
aux appétits petit chien petite gamelle
c'est clair
[Musique]
dit là-bas ya quoi
rien qui me concerne j attends l'esma
regarder gfr
vous êtes trop timides ils sont malins
ils savent qui est le patron non c'est
juste qu'elle refuse de coopérer
vous êtes en deuxième année de fac et
vous n'avez jamais fait ça non c'est
parce que j'ai dit d'accord coucher
souvenez vous vous êtes le maître pas
l'ami d'accord on les bat regardez bien
ouvrait lui la gueule et regarder ses
gencives ses dents c'est comme ça qu'on
fait un examen
d'accord d'accord bon chien à votre tour
à bouger
quoi qu'il en soit les papiers c'est un
plaisir de faire affaire avec vous merci
tout de suite de cars et faites
attention sur la route
merci
au plaisir
[Musique]
wilt hélas au pardon désolé désolé je
les jeunes et justement fermé la porte
non je voulais simplement savoir si tu
avais besoin d'un coup de main non ça va
allons voir où en sont les autres
[Musique]
tu es presque merci qu'est ce qui reste
à faire
[Musique]
dure journée fastoche
vous vous y ferez tenait à remercier le
dîner presque prêt merci
[Musique]
d'accord temps pose une phase ils
cherchent maladie de carré d'accord
quelle élégance tu dis quoi
[Musique]
car j'ai fait les réglages pour que les
vidéos s'enregistrent directement dans
un dossier sur ton bureau parfait et
encore merci pour ton aide
connecteraient à distance tous les soirs
je passerai les vidéos vues c'est
parfait merci je serai ici le propos ou
raccroche money il fait honneur à notre
invité tu devrais essayer d'en faire
autant je me suis lavé les endroits
importants
papa qui savait de new york était la
capitale du meurtre aux états unis bon
habits rangeois ce livre on va manger
bienvenus asseyez-vous là bas merci ça a
vraiment l'air délicieux
c'est gentil je veux les cuisses tu en
auras une c'est peut-être aussi ce que
sarah préfère chez ricoh à vrai dire
j'en mangerai pas c'est gentil mais je
suis végétarienne donc les légumes et
les pommes de terre suffire ans qu'ils
mangent pas de viande pour moi chérie
quand j'étais à l'école vétérinaire moi
aussi j'étais végétarienne mais quand
j'ai eu mon diplôme et j'ai pas su
résister donc d'accord vous êtes athée
aussi bien alors donnez leur la main
seigneur nous te remercions pour cette
table abondante qui nourrira notre
famille
[Musique]
salut bonjour jacky mcconnell sahara
gold ya trois semaines de ça j'ai trouvé
un drap tard qui s'était enfuie de chez
holloway il n'était pas en très bonne
état unitaire famille mais je sais j'ai
vu les photos oui donc je les récupérer
et je les emmener chez daniel qui m'a
regardé droit dans les yeux et qui a nié
qu'il était à lui avant de chasser la
propriété qu'il nous faut ce sont des
échantillons adn de préférence provenant
de toutes ces femelles draps tard afin
que je puisse prouver que le chien est
bien à l'us d'accord courte et sûrement
entendu on a aussi besoin de vidéo vous
les aurez on reste en contact
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et qu'est ce qu'il t'a demandé de faire
eux j'étais en train de vérifier si elle
était en période de chaleur quoi avec ça
ouais je comptais faire une analyse de
cytologie tu vois il ya il ya un truc
assez facile c'est quoi ok attraper un
train de tomber d'accord
à la base ok voilà tu sens à la fermeté
ouais ça veut dire qu'elle n'est pas
encore prête maintenant touche à lèvre
inférieure va essayer
tu sens comme ses mots c'est comme ça
que tu sais quel qui elle va entrer en
chaleur ces bâtiments scientifique mais
c'est le moyen le plus simple et si on
loupe un cycle ça nous coûte beaucoup
d'argent et bien sûr merci merci pour le
truc
oh
[Musique]
bonsoir vite
quoi de neuf comment balshaw
le chien avait la marque
avant ça je rappelle à vous je manque
pas d'animaux malades voient juste mon
chien j'arrive pas à le voir écouter l
exploit lui faire le test d'accord c'est
trop tard comment ça c'est trop grave
mais qu'est ce que tu as fait j'ai fait
voir à jack jack qui a tant pis tu tu
devrais en très bien je te servir non
écoute suis désolé lice mais il n'y a
plus vraiment raison d'en discuter
pourquoi est ce que tu as à monterey
jack alias mrc voir les démons et
l'examiner au chat qui avait raison à
propos de mme pitt ont peur rouge et ça
je te le promets
bonne nuit quitte
et
le sang
rien oui
will
[Musique]
il
merv discours je fasse de répéter encore
et encore il faut toujours plus
répertorié des chansons des maquilleurs
une erreur moi je comprends
pourquoi continuer à commettre les mêmes
erreurs témoin des bennes ne pas l'être
non non non c'était agréable d'être dans
la ligne de mire d'autres s'en sert
et quoi encore
c'était sûrement qu'à [ __ ] laveur
écoute arrangé avec pitt avant qu'il le
raconte dans tout conte est d'accord
voyez chef
oui
attends tu vas en guise ouais tu peux
venir pour quoi faire
je dois acheter quelques trucs à la
pharmacie
[Applaudissements]
attends attends à l'intérieur
e
[Musique]
ça va
et de quoi vous parlez de rien
je suis pas sûr d'avoir fait sa dernière
série de vaccins au chien qu'on lui a
vendu et c'est pour ça qu'il est tombé
malade
ils l'ont est anase y est
oui
où es tu
écoute ça ou ça sert à rien ne
culpabilisez c'était une simple erreur
réd il ya à mon père
[Musique]
vous avez tout ce qu'il faut et ils sont
tous étiquetés combien 15 ans tout au
plus un gars est passé hier soir martine
ouais c'est ça je sais j'ai examiné le
chiot j'avais prévenu à propos de lomé
et pour ce qui est de l'autre chaigneau
c'est lui qui est au fond il est
toujours fermée à clef mais j'y
travaille
d'accord continuer comme ça on va finir
par les avoir
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là toi
et à qui elle appartient la ferme de
l'autre côté au tonnerre ce sont des
éleveurs des éleveurs du dimanche de
chien de chasse
oui parfois ouais ben quand je suis allé
courir ce matin je suis tombée sur une
file qui m'a couru après elle ressemble
exactement à un des vôtres apparemment
elle a couru après oui en fait y avait
une clôture j'ai réussi à la passer sans
ça elle me revendu attend une seconde
puce et les deux orateurs dernière est
allée courir ce matin et s'est fait
attaquer par un chien chez les dernières
mais qu'est ce que le fichier sur leur
terrain ne le prends pas comme ça je
vais m'en occuper
non il faut qu'on en parle avec elle
garde un oeil sur l île d hui de ne pas
aller sur le terrain des voisins
[Musique]
pas
un panneau à l'entrée par dont j'étais
en train de faire mon jogging mais tu
fais du jogging par des siècles au tir
lors elle peut tirer dessus
j'aurais été dans un endroit tu sais je
suis vraiment désolé je ne savais pas
que quelqu'un vivent ici parce je vous
en prie c'est juste que j'ai vu un chien
et j'ai cru qu'il pouvait s'agir d'un
des nôtres ont des vôtres ouais ouais je
travaille pour daniel holloway
mais tu veux voir nos chiens c'est ça la
voisine
[Musique]
désolé pour le dérangement et les
nouvelles par ici ça se reproduira plus
non nous on n'aime pas trop les gens qui
s'introduisent sur notre propriété
nous non plus il ya une bonne torture
qui nous a volé deux chiens l'an dernier
qu'est-ce que tu essaies de dire là tout
simplement que ce serait dommage que
quelqu'un se fasse descendre pour un vol
de chiens
qu'est ce que tu faisais là bas j'ai dû
le chenil et j'ai entendu aboyer
je sais pas d'accord je sais pas je te
les 10 ces gens sont pas réglo ça craint
alors en ou services et reste loin d'eux
était chien tu veux pas les récupérer
c'est bien sûr mais une fois qu'ils
vivent dans cette crasse va savoir quel
genre de malade il pourrait se trimballe
il maltraite ses chiens où il tu ne peux
pas rester les bras croisés
et qu'est ce que tu veux que j'y fasse
un on arrive à peine à payer les
factures et à faire tourner le chenil
pourquoi ton père fait ce boulot alors
mon arrière arrière grand père sa tête
jacques holloway il il est arrivé ici à
travailler la terre et au moment de la
première guerre mondiale il avait mis de
côté assez d'argent pour acheter toute
la vallée 800 hectares
à l'époque avoir un chien de chasse
c'était une nécessité mais c'était aussi
ton ami ton seul outil pour survivre et
pour nourrir sa famille et puis le deux
pôles à débarquer et c'était presque
impossible de cultiver par ici les gens
ont dû tourner vers la chasse et les
chiens de chasse de jack holloway
étaient les meilleurs du coin donc c'est
une tradition dont mon père est plutôt
fier et puis surtout c'est la seule vie
qu'il ait jamais connu
[Musique]
et toi tu en est fier oui bien sûr c'est
juste que je suis pas sûr d'avoir envie
de rester bloqué ici comme lui
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
frans
qu'est ce que tu fais daniel t'a dit de
ne pas entrer ici je me trompe oui c'est
ce qu'il a dit oui effectivement mais
j'ai entendu des gémissements et je me
suis dit qu'il fallait que j'aille voir
qui avait pas de problème je savais pas
où vous étiez jeu voilà pourquoi c'est
si dur de lui faire comprendre qu'on a
besoin de stagiaires ici vous les jeunes
vous pensez tout savoir et vous ne savez
rien c'est une zone de quarantaine ici
ce pauvre chiot à la maladie de carré il
l'attrapé auprès d'un chien errant qui
est entré dans la propriété il l'a
transmise à celui là le fait tu viens
ici et tu les touches pourraient
infecter tous les chiens qu'on a je suis
vraiment désolé n'importe qui doute les
aurait fait piquer
je m'en vais je suis vraiment suis
vraiment 19 toiles est d'accord
[Musique]
salut salut tu veux voir un truc cool
hu oui elle était à mon grand père elles
étaient toutes rouillées et mes parents
voulaient la mettre à la casse mais je
pouvais pas les laisser faire
elle est magnifique j'ai tout fait moi
même ça m'a pris presque cinq ans
impressionnant tu veux la faire démarrer
[Rires]
j'arrive je n'arrive vraiment pas à
croire que tu fais ça tousse et ta
jamais pensé en faire ton métier
ouais j'avais des projets mais il ya
deux ou trois trucs qui sont passés ici
et j'ai dû rester
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mon père a eu
une crise cardiaque un mois ou deux
avant que je parte
je suis vraiment d'énormes le médecin a
dit qu'il se rétablirait complètement
mais ma mère et habib el elles ont eu
peur tu vois donc j'ai décidé de rester
pour donner un coup de main mais on
dirait que ton père est en excellente
santé
pourquoi tu pars pas maintenant ce qu'il
fait demande beaucoup de travail
s'il lui arrivait quoi que ce soit tu
sais je me le pardonnerai jamais
vraiment
peut-être quand l'habit sera plus grande
tu veux qu'on est en ville avec demain
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya
rien du tout
dix mois
non c'est juste que je croyais qu'elle
roulerait tu sais plus vite
[Musique]
ben je peux faire ça
bon il faut juste deux ou trois trucs on
se retrouve à la camionnette ouais
salut sahara
tu dis non oui il est là il faudrait
surtout pas qu'il nous voit toutes les
deux vous avez du nouveau ouais j'ai
quelques vidéos mais on devrait super
nounou le truc c'est que l'adn
correspond j'ai besoin d'une dernière
preuve et j'obtiendrai un mandat je
crois que ces chiens viennent pas de
chez eux mais d'une autre qui se trouve
juste à côté aucune importance l'adn
correspondait leur chien d'accord je
vois oui mais je crois que c'est un des
chiens qu'on leur a volé et en plus
quand leurs chiffres sont malades ils
émettent en quarantaine comment ça je
suis rentré dans le chenil du fond il y
avait deux chiens atteints de la maladie
de carré quoi attendait daniel et met en
quarantaine jaequi regarder
je veux cette vidéo
il les met en quarantaine sait ce qu'il
doit faire quand ils sont malades comme
vous voulez mais envoyer là moi et tout
de suite vous pouvez partager ses
fichiers
faites-le j'en ai besoin
c'est une très jolie camionnette oui et
si tu changes d'avis notre foi tient
toujours d'accord j'apprécie votre
intérêt et monsieur vente aux rois ou
est l'un de ces jours au revoir à nantes
des cris d'une grande le gars qui tient
concessionnaire du centre tu me laisses
conduire pour le retour
tu as le droit de calais 3 fois et qui
t'a dit que j'allais calais
j'ai parlé avec qui elle m'a dit les
choses avancer très vite
comment ça eh bien on a des preuves non
il n'y a aucune preuve
écoute on est très conscient on va y
arriver
qu'est-ce qui s'est pas exactement ce
que je dois raccrocher on voit ces
picards désolé de peinture ou non c'est
bon j'étais en train de parler avec mon
père j'ai besoin d'un coup de main ouais
bien sûr tu as bien travaillé petites
marques nous les petits sont là ouais il
y en a 6 ans tout pesé mesuré
oui voilà génial bon boulot aller la
chercher
ab le même incident
voilà bon chien ou bon chien c'est bien
c'est un bon chiffre ça c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est une âme
bien et était partante pour une petite
virée tout ça appartient ta famille
ouais on en avait plus mais mon père a
été contraint d'en vendre pour pouvoir
joindre les deux bouts
j'hallucine c'est comme un fond d'écran
vivant ouais il vendra jamais
cette partie de notre terrain
[Musique]
au fait j'ai reçu un appel de mon tuteur
de stage
ah ouais ouais je dois m'en aller avant
la date prévue il veut que je rentre ah
ouais mais je comprends
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu regardes
quant à madame la citadine s'ennuie déjà
non c'est juste que si tu comptes tenter
quelque chose tu devrais peut-être
dépêcher parce qu'on change
regarde là tout droit
[Musique]
non ils arrivent paribas reste où tu es
resto tuer les sucres au vert
[Musique]
elle
tandis quoi que tu es plutôt charmant
will holloway
[Musique]
ou est ce que tu vas seller de tous
fermés je vais le faire fais attention
[Musique]
tout doux bon
mon coeur ça va le coeur ça va dire oui
ne le touche et surtout pas il est
peut-être orages et mais d'où est ce
qu'il vit un bon sens c'est un des
chiens des tonnerres ça va pas nous
avons chéri
[Musique]
il
daniel
chérie qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel
oui
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ghania chérif
attendez qu est ce qui se passe là
daniel holloway on a un mandat pour
fouiller la propriété à daisy allez les
gars on attendait que meadow prouesse
convaincu et c'est exactement
maltraitance envers des animaux
domestiques et vous vous basez sur quoi
c'est jacky mcconnell qui vous happe
laissé sa marque
je sais pas ce qu'elle a pu te raconter
mais elle a menti éviter que ces gars se
met en travers de mon chemin
qu'est ce qui se passe n'a été dégagé
monsieur écarté tout nous avoir mon
d'artois s'il te plaît martin pannier je
te demande d'être calmé allez-y après
harry va vite aller au boulot
m
et qu'est ce qu'on a fait d'après ce
rapport aux chiens sont en mauvaise
santé
qu'est ce que tu racontes enfin je suis
vétérinaire ils sont parfaitement non
car cela vous fait d'être maintien
attendez ce sont des chiens ils vivent
sous mon toit ils vont les tuer c'est
les fonds sortis à baisser oui non stop
on est autorisé à prendre tous les
chiens de l'entreprise et ses champs où
le son monsieur écoutez vous pouvez pas
vous avez posé et qu'outre histoire t'es
pas un fait qui n'a pas bien ce qu'il
doit faire ou non bon sens daniel
pourquoi est ce que tu as fait ce enfin
arrêter là chez moi
[Musique]
voilà un outil un peu ouais ouais c'est
super comme ça tu vas éteindre ce à quoi
je comprends vraiment pas pourquoi vous
êtes venus c'est grâce à tout ce que tu
as fils mais de quoi tu parles
ta vidéo a su convaincre
quoi
oui beagle
[Musique]
où est ce qu'ils les hommes n 12 notons
fait pas je lui ramène très vite à la
maison
allez il faut qu'on rentre et on doit
avertir notre cas
je crois qu'il emmène les chiens au
champ de foire comment tu sais ça je les
ai entendu parler il faut qu'on aille
voir le shérif avec ma mère doit y aller
il te plait will s'il te plaît on peut
encore faire quelque chose mais on doit
y aller tu m'entends d'accord mais
laisse moi parler avec ma mère d'accord
d'accord
[Musique]
daniel mais moi que tu ne feras rien de
stupide
ah parce que vouloir récupérer mes
charges c'est quelque chose de stupide
ils les ont saisi de façon légale
une enquête criminelle est en cours on
ne peut rien faire tant qu'ils n'ont pas
fini de les examiner
ouais c'est ce qu'on va voir oui dans
les a tous ils sont en sécurité espèces
dont flir quoi ton problème tu es folle
kwata truquée les images très fort ce
chien était en train d'attaquer sa fille
c'est la seule raison pour laquelle il
n'a tué tu sais ça j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
tu viens de retirer cette famille sa
seule activité une famille qui
considèrent les chiens comme des
produits avant une famille qui
respectent la loi et qui tient ses
chiens une famille qui font des chiens
de chasse élevé afin de traquer d'autres
animaux tel quel côté je te dis de ces
gens n'ont rien fait de mal
mon seul but c'est de freiner
l'exploitation animale
quel qu'en soit le prix
aimant ouais on dirait que sarah avait
raison ils sont au champ de foire
chérissez oui ici qu'ils sont au champ
de foire d'accord valeur était lui qu'on
arrive à brest où tu es on est en chemin
je sais pas comment de jacky mcconnell a
pu se retrouver à la tête d'une
organisation qui défend les animaux
elle n'a aucune idée de la façon dont on
s'occupe des animaux absolument aucune
et c'est pas notre message
tu le connais ou quoi
non
j'ai essayé d'obtenir des informations
mon père est là
bien
[Musique]
ils les retiennent à l'intérieur dans
des enclos à bétail dans des enclos à
bétail
moi
cette pathétique mais c'est quoi votre
problème
et attendez vous n'avez pas le droit
d'être ici monsieur noël vous devez
partir immédiatement
non vous avez préféré le droit de voir
dans quel environnement vous avez placé
mes chiens on les traite mieux ici que
vous ne les avez jamais traité qu'est ce
que vous dites
il ya eu tous est de nouveau nés qui
n'ont reçu aucun vaccin et qui sont au
contact avec d'autres chiens dans un
endroit calcul du bétail
c'est un outil de réflexion et de
maladie daniel on a pris toutes les
précautions nécessaires et il ya
vingt-quatre autres chiens qui sont
toujours en attente de leur dernier
l'accent que vous entendez consulter
leur dossier ou moins a suffi on à la
situation en main au loin s'en faut
vous devez vous emballez c'est quoi
cette merde se voulant donner à bouffer
je leur ai apporté ce que je veux c'est
bien ça le cui courrier du jour phelan
plage à manger ça suffit mcconnell
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce que vous
faites
[Musique]
papa espagnols appelés score 5 à 28
il nous faut une ambulance ici j'ai un
adulte à terre vient de perdre
connaissance
[Musique]
on doit l'emmener à l'hôpital pour qu'un
médecin examine et s'assurer tout va
bien attendez attendez attendez
plus aux commandes je t'en prie et dis
moi que ça va aller
ils vont l'emmener à l'hôpital un
médecin doit l'examiner
ma mère veut qu'on reste là tous les
trois tu rentres avec la camionnette
ouais
en ce moment même à l'intérieur de cette
étable 86 chien reçoivent les premiers
soins et de la nourriture
après que l'ua pea et réussi à les
saisir dans ce qu'elle appelle une usine
à chiens cette vidéo qui a été diffusée
par l'association montre ce que les
activistes pour la cause animale
considère comme des conditions
insalubres
on va trouver ses chiens dans des
conditions absolument horrible il vivait
dans des bâtiments délabrés marché dans
leurs excréments entre autres c'est un
refuge insalubres sur une échelle de 1 à
10 est définitivement un neuf
on soumet chaque animal un examen
complet pour détecter des signes d'abus
de négligence de malnutrition ou encore
de tout genre de traumatisme qu'ils
auraient pu recevoir et on va continuer
à veiller sur ces animaux dans qu'une
enquête serait en cours
nos bénévoles travailleront 24 heures
sur 24 possibles autant dire que cette
opération restera en place jusqu'à ce
que l'affairé soit résolue ici michael
heinze pour le journal de canal au tv
news a march field
[Musique]
oh
il faut que je te dise quelque chose
quoi qu'est ce qu'il ya sarah tu es fier
de toi j'espère que ce que tu as tiré
tout ça en valait la peine
demande lui oui vas-y demande lui si
elle connaît les gens qui sont venus
chez nous et qui ont pris tout le chien
tu les connais depuis le début on m'a
envoyé ici pour enquêter sur vos
activités et vérifier que tout était sûr
et en or et ça l'était ou devrais je
dire ça l'est encore on marie le père de
mes enfants est maintenant dans un lit
d'hôpital
alors est-ce que tout est en ordre non
je suis vraiment désolé laissez moi être
votre témoin laissez-moi allé les voir
et leur dire ce que j'ai vu ici parce
que ce que vous faites ne va pas à
l'encontre de la réglementation je
croyais que tu étais mon ami je siège
ça devait passer comme ça je veux
surtout ce tout ce qu'on fait dans le
carton qui sait on
je veux que tu le dises je veux que tu
sois honnête avec nous alors pour qui tu
travailles
je travaille pour l'association de
protection uva pea
maintenant je veux que tu fasses tes
valises et tu t'en ailles tout de suite
on
oui va-t-en non je t'en prie l'attend
s'il te plait je t'attends
[Musique]
magnifique non non
avec un feu à new york
deux samoa
c'est moi cathy simpson je chante de
tout mon coeur ça vous le savez mais mon
coeur appartient à ces innocents animaux
tous les jours des animaux sans défense
sont maltraités battus et négligé tout
ce qu'ils veulent c'est qu'on les aide
appelée aujourd'hui le numéro qui
s'affiche pour faire aux donations à lui
ap hm
de cette façon vous contribuerez au
sauvetage d'animaux maltraités
grâce à vos dons nous leur apportons
soins nourriture un toit et de l'amour
en ce moment même un animal a besoin de
vous avec un simple appel
vous lui direz je peux aider j'adore
j'ai fait en sorte canal diffuse tout de
suite je parie qu'on va doubler les
bénéfices par rapport aux derniers spa
et voilà deux superstars attend de voir
notre nouveau stade du pid ça va faire
le buzz
quand tu y vas jamais croire qu'il m'a
appelé ce matin même le président du
comité du sénat pour le bien-être des
animaux et c'est lui qui m'a appelé oui
il se trouve que c'est le plus grand
démantèlement de fabrique de cheveux de
toute l'histoire de cet état ça va être
énorme pour nous on a vraiment attiré
son attention qu'il est prêt à nous
écouter cette fois ne vaut tard que
jamais donc maintenant on peut faire
tout ce qu'on veut
et tout ça c'est grâce à toi trevor a
falsifié la vidéo directrice
d'opérations ton propre bureau
les notes de frais vous n'avez pas
entendu ce que je viens de dire il faut
que je donne cette promotion à quelqu'un
d'autre
trevor inventé toute cette histoire il a
détruit une famille kaci il a retiré son
moyen de subsistance et sa réputation
je dirais qu'ils sont les seuls
responsables non j'ai passé un certain
temps avec cette famille que si et
daniel mc chien autant qu'il aime ses
enfants
oui sahara c'est aussi l'un des pires
opposants à la proposition 12 et la
vidéo n'est pas la seule preuve qu'on
m'a très fort et scott sont allés sur
place ils sont dit que les conditions
étaient déplorables
parmi les pires qui ne s'est jamais vu
tout ça c'est faux j'y étais j'ai été
pendant des semaines on vous opinions
divergent
ce sont les faits cas si c'est pas une
opinion il est fait que tu défends
ont-ils un quelconque rapport avec ta
relation avec le fils de l'eau et jack
qui dit que tous les deux vous êtes
assez proche avec will on est justement
en fin
c'est une petite victoire pour les
millions d'animaux qui n'ont pas de voix
d'accord penseurs et les dommages
collatéraux vous en faites quoi ré enfin
la guerre continue je veux que mes
soldats soit investi à 100% tu vois non
je me suis pas engagée pour ça d'accord
e
d'abord félicitations merci au boulot
bravo qui est très reconnaissant pour
cette c'est gmail a réservé un bureau à
l'étagé supérieur
je pense qu'on devrait changer d'air
favery partir quelque part les étagères
m'ont proposé de passer pour le pont et
puis margaret et là bas ces jours ci
qu'est ce que t'en dis maman margaret et
moi on était amis en sixième bon c'est
juste une idée c'est une bonne idée
chérie comment s'est passé l'entretien
pour d'agde est bien bien je sais tout
ça s'est bien passé
très bien et tu pense qu'ils vont te
faire une proposition
certainement certainement
c'est fantastique c'est une très bonne
nouvelle elle écoute mais arrêtez ça
maintenant arrêtez de faire comme si
rien ne s'était passé parce que j'ai
fait du mal à pas mal de gens tu ma
chérie c'est pas danger une d'or maman
écoute cette ferme appartient à cette
famille depuis des générations il
pourrait tout perdre et je suis source
est restée assise là à dîner comme si
rien ne s'était passé sauf que je sais
que j'ai eu tort
chiali
[Musique]
m
non maman à l'entretien et à anzin oui
c'est largement le temps de diriger une
fabrication
un homme de 54 ans daniel holloway fait
l'objet de 86 chefs d'accusation de
cruauté envers les animaux
s'il est condamné il risque la prison à
perpétuité un an par cette accusation la
fameuse associations de défense animale
a perquisitionné sa propriété le mois
dernier après la diffusion a donné une
vidéo où l'on voit l'homme battre
anciens jusqu'à le tuer
l'organisation suspecté au loup est
depuis longtemps de vendre des animaux
malades parce que si je ne fais rien je
serais incapable de me le pardonner
oui juste assez pour le billet d'avion
je te le promets d'accord merci je
t'aime très fort baba
[Musique]
dr reddick qu'avez vous découvert après
avoir examiné les chiens qui ont été
saisis sur la propriété des holloway ils
vivaient dans des conditions insalubres
il avait pas assez de nourriture ni
d'eau et beaucoup d'entre eux utilisés
dans leurs propres excréments
après inspection plus poussée au champ
de foire du compte et nous avons trouvé
que 32 des chiens a été infecté par des
vairons vous n'avez pas besoin de mon
expertise sinon de sens commun cinq
personnes ne peuvent tout simplement pas
s'occuper correctement de son chien
c'est la définition même de la
négligence
merci pas d'autres questions votre
beurre docteur l'automne n'êtes-vous pas
avec le docteur die les deux docteurs
reddick tous les trois membres du
conseil d'administration de l'uap et à 6
mais nous sommes aussi des terrines air
et à nous trois nous accumulons 60 ans
d'expérience la position de l'ua bea sur
ce genre d'élevage sachant qu'il est
complètement légal est néanmoins qu'il
ne devrait pas exister
oui
merci je n'ai pas d'autres questions
mais s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
écoute je sais que tu as sûrement aucune
envieuses mais laisse moi vous aider je
t'en prie en est en plein coeur d'une
bataille d'experts et les juges et les
jurés ont naturellement tendance à se
rallier aux experts et ses experts là
sont en train de le crucifier
et si on a mené nos propres experts on
l'a fait mais il coûte cher on ne peut
pas se permettre
la seule solution ce serait de vendre le
terrain derrière avec les chevaux on n'a
pas le choix je pourrais servir des
témoins votre relation avec will entache
votre crédibilité très bien et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour gagner alors il
n'y a qu'une solution attaquer leur
crédibilité
donc on en revient à la proposition 12
la réforme d'usinage chien quoi ils
veulent attaquer mon père parce qu'ils
s'opposent à cette loi de toutes ses
forces
s'il disque réside ton pain ils disent
critique l'opposition ils auront gagné
affaires classées à temps par dont la
réforme du sinn un chien oui la
proposition douzaine rendre illégal le
fait de garder les animaux dans des
cages au sol grillagé ça pousserait
l'état nerfs à la faillite donc je
comprends pas pourquoi ton père s'y
oppose pas sûr qu aucune loi ne pourra
dissuader des gens comme l'état nerfs
ils n'hésitent pas à violer des
douzaines de lois existantes sur le
bien-être des animaux
la proposition 12 places les éleveurs de
leur trempe et les éleveurs descend dans
le même panier
elle mettra fin à l'élevage c'est son
seul objectif à long terme et c'est pour
ça que mon père la redoute
et dix au fait on va où voir jack et
pourquoi
le refuge est à court de nourriture elle
n'a pas les moyens de nourrir tous les
chiens comment ça j'en sais rien les
dons se font rares les taux attendus
très bien
prenez ces deux-là effet tout on va
fermer vous devez vous en aller non on
doit encore voir le border collie on va
faire mais je n'ai pas le temps de vous
le montrer
c'est ridicule je vois pas quel sens ça
c'est notre chien de compagnie
laissez-nous au moins le voir jaqee ça
ne prendra qu'une minute le chien est
dans une famille d'accueil
nos chiens sont dans des familles
d'accueil on n'avait pas le choix et ses
petits alors on manque de nourriture
l'accord est impossible uatp à bout
donnent de la nourriture le semo voir
votre inventaire attendez vous avez bien
un inventaire pas vrai on compte sur des
bénévoles à mi temps tout ce qu'ils ont
à nous offrir ça un peu de leur temps
avec l'instant on fait de notre mieux
ces chiens sont des pièces à conviction
dans la protéger suis désolé vous devez
partir
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont bien pu en faire
j'ai pas le refuge organise cette foire
à l'adoption dans des boutiques
d'animaux en ville sont peut être là bas
ce sont des pièces à conviction donc les
données peut être considérée comme une
entrave à la justice ou de la négligence
il faudrait qu'on puisse le prouver
madame mcconnell nous a recommandé
d'éviter d'acheter ce chien à monsieur
holloway tiens donc et vous at-elle dit
pourquoi parce qu'il a eu une usine à
chiens du moins c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit
je n'ai pas écouté son conseil et j'ai
acheté un chien monsieur holloway quand
même et ensuite deux semaines plus tard
le chien avait l'air fatigué il est
tombé malade a perdu l'appétit
et il est la diarrhée bref tous les
symptômes de la parvovirose que c'était
le passé ensuite on a conduit le chien
refuge de madame mcconnell et c'est là
où il s'est révélé positif au test du
par vos virus ça vous a peiné bien sûr
oui je venais à peine de leur lâcher une
sacrée cent mille dollars
ce chien aurait dû avoir tous ces
vaccins monsieur martin
qu'est-il arrivé à votre chien
eh ben on adule euthanasié madame
mcconnell nous a recommandé de le faire
merci quand un chien est vaccinée contre
le parvovirus il peut arriver que le
test soit positif à cause du vaccin
mais ce chien on avait tous les
symptômes il est possible que le chien
ait eu un simple cas dans kg ce tome aux
qui est rentable et non mortels pour un
chien il aurait fallu vérifier si le
chien avait des verts avant de l'auto
nasier dans ce cas pourquoi avez vous
remboursez monsieur martin alors parce
que mon fils n'était pas sûre à 100%
d'avoir terminé la dernière série
d'injections sans procéder à une
autopsie
il est impossible de savoir de quoi
souffrait exactement l'animal cependant
nous voulons que tous nos clients soient
satisfaits et nous sommes très fiers de
notre travail
merci pas d'autres questions puissent
interroger à nouveau le témoin allez-y
bien madame holloway votre fils avoue
une possible négligence et assumer la
responsabilité de la mort du chien de
monsieur martin c'est bien cela oui mais
madame holloway êtes vous une
vétérinaire accrédités disons que suite
à certains problèmes de santé de mon
mari je n'ai pas pu renouveler ma
licence b sont dernière chose m nous
aimons les animaux j'ai travaillé dans
un refuge et c'est pour ça que je suis
devenu vétérinaire
merci madame ce sera tout ouais on m'en
a donné 12 il me faut les adresses des
nouveaux propriétaires
ou est-ce que vous avez eu ce chien les
prix en adoption dans un refuge
je suis désolé mais il appartient à
quelqu'un et on va devoir le récupérer
je comprends pas un truc
pourquoi est ce qu on me l'aurait donné
s'il appartient à quelqu'un d'autre avez
vous adopté un drap tard auprès du
refuge récemment je suis du ap hm le
chien vous a été donné par erreur je
vais devoir le reprendre c'est quoi
ça en fait 5
voici les images de la perquisition
menée à la ferme des olo et par l'uap et
à vous remarquerez que les chiens son
propre bien traités bien nourris et
n'ont pas l'air stressé
monsieur joyner vous vous estimez
experts sur le sujet comment vivez vous
évaluer leur état à 9 sur une échelle de
1 à 10 10 étant la pire note
les chiens étaient nerveux peut
sociabiliser j'ai vu les infections
cutanées et au niveau des yeux des
parasites salon monsieur joyner sur les
100 chiens il y en a que 6 qui était
souffrant
désinfection des plus communes qui
étaient toutes en cours de traitement
il y en avait deux atteints de la
maladie de carré et ses deux chiens
justement était correctement placés en
quarantaine est en bonne voie de
guérison avant votre intervention
et c'est tout non alors ça nous fait 29
chien portées disparues où est ce qu'ils
sont je sais pas mais c'est de la
négligence oui en se débarrassant de ils
sont éliminés des preuves peut pas
prouver que c'était volontaire et
pourquoi ça parce que c'est une
organisation gérée par des bénévoles et
non par des professionnels ils
déclareront que ce genre de personne
peut commettre des erreurs
et si on arrivait à impliquer un
professionnel dans cette histoire ça
nous ferait avancer à quoi vous pensez
[Musique]
monsieur le web avez vous déjà mal
traiter vos chiens n'ont jamais et les
enclos ce tome aux les verront les
oxyures un de ces parasites représentent
ils un danger mortel pour vos animaux
non pas tant que les protocoles
antiparasitaires sont appliquées et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec votre
chien compagnie aussi évidemment où est
votre chien de compagnie monsieur
holloway ma chienne de compagnie des
lilas nous a été confisquée par l'ua pea
avec sa portée nouveau né savez vous où
sont vos chiens présents
je lis n'y a pas d'autres questions
votre mère le témoin est à vous monsieur
nous donne votre verre monsieur le web
avez vous déjà tué un animal disons de
manière cruelle
bien sûr que non je vais demander aux
membres du jury de regarder les images
suivantes
monsieur webb cette vidéo est truqué
elle a été recadrée on l'a déjà expliqué
plusieurs fois là n'est pas la question
je veux juste savoir si c'est vous qui
frappe et ce chien avec une pelle ou non
objection direction rejetée veuillez
répondre monsieur louis ce chien est
entré sur mon terrain par accident et il
menaçait d'attaquer ma fille qui comme
par hasard se trouvent hors champ du
moins c'est ce que vous dites
ce chien était une menace pour ma
famille et oui oui oui je les fais et si
je devais le refaire je le referais nous
voilà donc un acte digne d'un individu
tu es plus violents en direction
monsieur longueur vous vous trouveriez
la même chose aussi sur moi qui suis en
train d'être jugé maintenir le web
sections une section t'il un pilote
généré nage je suspends la science pour
une période de trente minutes
je veux voir tout de suite les avocats
étaient deux parties entendu
[Applaudissements]
ça
à
est ce que je peux vous parler une
minute non je ferais viennent je veux
juste jeter un coup d'oeil à l'internât
c'est interdit d'entrée alors vous
pouvez me dire pourquoi 29 des chiens
holloway sont introuvables
je peux pas parler avec vous vous savez
ce que je pense que vous savez ce qui
leur est arrivé que vous êtes quelqu'un
de bien et que vous allez m'aider
ma femme est loin d'être enfant et ce
travail c'est tout ce qui nous reste
donc vous trouvez ça normal de laisser
un homme innocent finir le reste de ses
jours en prison
il ya deux ou trois semaines le champ de
foire été réquisitionnés alors on a dû
amener les chiens des holloway ici sauf
qu'ici d'habitude il y a que 50 chiens
avec tous ceux des holloway il y en
avait 150 tout à coup
ils étaient tous là les uns sur les
autres
on n'avait pas assez de nourriture à
leur donner
dites moi ce que vous avez fait
il faut que vous compreniez que c'est
difficile pour moi trouver du travail
pourquoi ça
giflés de la prison c'est tout c'est pas
facile
mais c'est quoi cette odeur
ou est ce qu'on est
on y est
vincent
bah ça
[Musique]
par ici
à part vous a tué une douzaine de chiens
en une seule nuit
j'ai dû tuer ceux qui restent et jacky
savez savez pas quoi faire
une des cadres de l'uap est à nous a
appelés a dit que je devais m'en
débarrasser jacky m'a dit fais ce
qu'elle disait j'ai fait partie d'un
programme de dressage de chiens en
prison vous savez l essieu mon était
reprendre ma vie en main et c'est pas
plus je pouvais pas les jeter comme ça
au milieu de ses ordures alors je leur
ai offert des funérailles dignes de ce
nom
juste là
vincent qu'est ce qui est arrivé aux
colis attraper la toux de chenil d'un
autre chien est important
et c'est ti alors j'ai pas trop à loana
c'est sarah tu es prête à vraiment faire
bouger les choses
et qu'est ce qui t'a fait changer d'avis
je suis désolé au sujet de notre
dernière conversation et j'ai beaucoup
appris
de toute cette histoire comme quoi je
vais aller voir jaqee dans son refuge et
ce qui m'a choqué c'est que malgré tout
l'argent que lui a faits à lui ai donné
l'arrivée toujours pas s'occuper de ces
aliments
oui c'est vrai et je ne réalisais pas le
poids qu'a notre organisation dans le
fond l'organisation est la seule chose
qui importe
tu comprends ça je sais est en fait ce
que je veux dire c'est que maintenant je
m'en rends compte
[Musique]
elle a dit qu'elle serait là ça vaut
mieux pour nous
depuis combien de temps êtes-vous
officière de contrôle des animaux cinq
ans vous considérez vous comme une
experte en ce qui concerne le soin des
animaux
oui tout à fait lors de l'intervention
vous avez utilisé un camion de l'ue à
payer afin de transporter les chiens des
holloway ce même camion avait été
utilisé lors des missions précédentes
afin de transporter des animaux morts
exact oui le camion il était désinfecter
avant l'intervention à la ferme holloway
je suis sûr que l'équipe de l'uap et à
s'en est occupé auriez-vous des
documents qui soutiennent cela non les
tables du champ de foire du comté est
souvent utilisée pour garder le bétail
les mesures de biosécurité nécessaires
ont elles été appliquée les chiens de
lauwe ait été si mal en point car ces
majorités tout est inutile
suite à la saisie dites nous combien de
ces chiens ont donné un résultat positif
pour le parvovirus combien aucun combien
sont décédés sous votre tutelle
objection votre honneur mme adama koné
n'est pas l'accuser ici
cette question est pertinente quant à la
crédibilité du témoin qui prétend être
une experte en soin d'animaux me rejeter
s'ils vous plairait pour dire est
question madame mcconnell je répète
combien de chiens de monsieur holloway y
sont morts sous votre tutelle
combien je ne fais pas de quoi vous
parlez vous êtes sous serment madame
mcconnell je vais les comptes est pour
vous fat neuf chiens sont morts 29
objections objections rejetée
du calme silence silence nous avons ici
les rapports d'autopsié des 29 chien la
plupart desquelles ont contracté sont
morts de la parvovirose alors qu'ils
étaient avec vous c'est extrêmement
commun est vraiment contagieux avez vous
vacciner ces chiens contre la part vos
noms nous manquions de temps évidemment
de ressources
pourquoi on était plutôt dépassée des
promesses nous avaient été faites mais
elles n'ont pas été inspectés
arrive-t-on qui vous a fait ses
promesses
lui a pris
silence croyez-vous que l'élevage de
chiens devraient être autorisés non il
ne devrait pas l'être
voilà de quoi il est question pas vrai
de faire tomber mon client par tous les
moyens possibles comme le dicte lui ap
hm quand bien même cela impliquerait de
commettre le même crime pour lequel vous
l'accusez objection votre honneur
objection section retenu votre honneur
j'ai une nouvelle pièce à présenter
j'aimerais soumettre au jury cette pièce
à conviction des de la partie civile
votre honneur le parquet n'a pas
connaissance d'une nouvelle pièce à
conviction permission accordée
ça va vous plaire
l'organisation est la seule chose qui
importe tu comprends ça je sais est en
fait ce que je veux dire c'est que
maintenant je m'en rends compte
on ne peut pas s'occuper de tous les
chiens errants et leur trouver oui on
doit s'en prendre à la source du
problème
aller à l'essentiel et si des animaux
doit souffrir en cours de route
qu'importe exact oui on travaille à un
niveau plus abstrait avant tout on
cherche à sensibiliser c'est une
question de chiffres
pourquoi doit-on gaspiller de l'argent
pour des animaux perdu d'avancé
tout à fait j'ai néanmoins encore une
question pourquoi doit-on faire semblant
de nous intéresser réellement aux
animaux c'est vrai on demande des dons
et on fait croire aux personnes qui nous
aident qu'ils vont sauver des animaux
j'ai vérifié avec la comptabilité vous
n'avez pas donné un dollar à jaqee afin
qu'elle s'occupe de ses chiens sarah
écoute on dépense tout notre argent pour
changer la législation
saeed des millions d'animaux et c'est ce
qui marque vraiment la différence
on a rigolé pas loin de 160 millions de
dollars l'année dernière
qu'est ce que tu as une idée de ce que
ça coûte de faire passer une loi au
sénat
j'ai aussi trouvé ça
le comique est très élevé et alors il
est daté de trois jours avant
l'intervention trois jours avant que
personne ne souhaite aller sur la
propriété on écrit toujours les
premières versions à l'avance oui mais
cette version est quasi identique à
celle qui a été diffusé des chiens qui
vivent dans leurs propres excréments
lerner veut ma nourrice et quoi que ce
soit de tous avait été vrai je vous
l'aurais signaler et vous le savez de
toute façon vous essaieriez allez quoi
qu'il arrive tu peux t'en allait
continuer or j'ai pas encore fini on en
arrive à ma partie préférée
vous voyez je peux prouver que vous avez
ordonné un des employés du refuge de se
débarrasser des chiens dont vous ne vous
êtes pas occupé vous avez laissé les
chiens de l'om mourir et puis vous les
avez fait disparaître mince alors je me
demande ce qu'en diront les donateurs
lors de la prochaine collecte de fonds
mais un jouet voilà la vraie sarah caché
derrière son sourire adorable
d'accord tout ce que tu as fait ton
propre bureau notes de frais inclus tout
ce que tu voudras maintenant je veux que
tout disparaisse
ça vous plairait 1 mais vous voyez ça
ferait moins quelqu'un comme moi et
jamais je ne serais qu'un jour
restons-en là
brad je crois qu'on a un problème est ce
que vous pouvez apporter ça en
comptabilité et trouve et chaparral à
saragosse
oui bien sûr et fermé la porte en
sortant pas problème merci c'est
l'affairé holloway
tu sais elle refuse de lâcher prise
nous déclarons accusé daniel holloway
non coupable de tous les chefs
d'accusation
[Musique]
merci
et voilà
[Musique]
on
c'est en faudra
merci c'est tout naturel d'annuaire
[Musique]
oh
je suis vraiment déçu
tout est fini
monsieur ou monsieur louer michael
heinze pour caldo tv comment vous
sentez-vous à l'issue de ce verdict très
reconnaissant tout le nom de la famille
holloway et été blanchi et que la
justice était rendue est très fatigué on
rentre à la maison
oui y rentrer
[Musique]
h
oui pour ça ça c'est la boucherie
[Musique]
en effet le nom
ils auraient droit comme feu
[Musique]
ça
q
[Musique]
and the fine
juncker dans mes os
c'est ma faveur
oui mais
k
là
voilà
[Musique]
m
ou une mort
soit
témoin
j'aime
[Musique]
est non
à
ce nom
[Musique]
un meuble